what's up good friends please watch this
video to not get scammed hey everyone in
this video we'll be covering common
scams in the nft space and how to
protect yourself scammers are becoming
more and more deceptive as more new
people enter the nft space one of the
biggest things you can do to protect
yourself is triple checking the url of
any site that you're trying to reach you
can minimize your risk of getting
scammed by making sure that the urls
you're clicking on are legit please
please please make sure you're on the
actual url the fake url is tricky
tricking so many people that is the key
make sure you're on the right url and
when you click the contract make sure
you see what it says it's getting access
to please be careful
many scam sites are made to look
identical to the site that you're
familiar with but the url will be
slightly different so check for extra
letters different site extensions or
similar looking characters one example
is a scam happening within the ads
section of google search when users
search v-friends on google the top of
the search results is sometimes
populated by fake v-friends websites
please note that these sites are paid
ads and they're not real the official
v-friends website url is vfriends.com
never click the link to a site that's
not valid by far the thing that i see
more than anything right now is people
getting caught on a fake url thus
exposing their wallet and getting scam
[ __ ] fake urls we need to cover the two
main ways that someone can get scammed
the first is by revealing your secret
phrase also known as your seed phrase a
secret phrase is a series of words that
is your way of accessing your wallet
from any device make sure your secret
phrase is written down on a piece of
paper and that you have more than one
copy most importantly don't give it out
to anyone the second way you can get
scammed is by connecting your wallet and
authorizing a malicious transaction for
example on a fake website url these
aren't the only ways a scam can occur
but these are the most common so where
can scams take place scammers most
commonly work through fake dms fake
twitter profiles fake tweets fake emails
and on discord sometimes they might also
hack verified twitter accounts scammers
often use discord dms to try and lure
victims to malicious sites with discord
nitro scammers can choose any username
they can even impersonate gary when
sending messages and may send links to
fake urls regardless of whether scammers
hack twitter accounts or send you
discord dms if you ever receive a
message or see a post that promises any
exclusive minting opportunities through
a link please make sure to thoroughly
verify it now let's dive into a couple
of specific examples of scams that
happened in the past one example is a
scam that happened during the apecoin
launch scammers hacked verified twitter
accounts during the launch and those
hacked accounts that had blue check
marks and board ape yacht club profile
pictures directed users to click on
malicious links users that clicked the
links were taken to a fake site
connected their wallet and got scammed
apecoin put out a link of the only
official website another well-known scam
offered to animate your nft these
scammers hacked verified twitter
accounts and those accounts that also
had blue check marks directed users to a
malicious link pretending to animate
their nfts to recap the surefire way to
not get scammed is to make sure that
you're on the right url there are three
ways to do that one type out the right
url yourself two click the url in bio of
the verified twitter profile of the
project you're trying to connect with
three when you're signing a transaction
verify the origin url of the transaction